يعني انا احبك مو بايدي شو اسوي يعني بنيه
من طالبه جامعه الى نجمه بالسوشال ميديا
الله اكو واحد ابن امه وابوه يقدر يتجرع
عليه
مرحبا
يلقي مسلسل كاتم العراقي واللي وصف
بالجريء جدا الضوء على علاقات المال
والمصالح واللي تتعارض عشان تشكل احداث
خطيره ومثيره ايش معنى هاي القضيه يريدون
يوصلون بيها للحقيقه استاذه جميل فورا
بالاعلانات تعرفت على الحاج وضعها تحسن من
الاعمال اللي تقدر تقول قصتها مثيره للجدل
يعني تتناول موضوع العصر اللي هو حاليا
البلوجرات
القصه ماخوذه من قصه حقيقيه يعني مقتبس من
عندها مو مو كلها بحذافيرها من تاليف
الاستاذ احمد هاتف واشتغلنا على المعالجه
الدراميه مع الاستاذ موفق مسعود من سوريا
العمل جريء اليوم مثلا اكو هوايه اشياء
مثلا الناس تشوفها من وجهه نظر
بس اللي وجهه نظر الحقيقيه ما مكشوفه
للعلم قصه عشق تجمع
الغلبه لشخصيه تبث الرعب حولها او
الفاشونيستا تتحكم بالراي العام يعني
ترى الدوله ما تحب تسوي مشاكل ويا ابو
لبنى واذا لسى
الظاهره رقم واحد هناك تابع لهم
مصور خريج اكاديميه فنون طموح يحب يشتغل
بس ما لاقي الفرصه
اجت الفرصه عن طريق بنيه
قام يحبها مشكله العمل مالتنا يعني
مو بالافراد المجتمع يعني الناس الاشخاص
اللي اكبر من عندنا
اللي صعب ممكن يسيطر عليهم دوري هو الرائد
زهير المحقق اللي يحقق بقضيه
جريمه قتل هزه الراي العام فهو يستك هذا
المسلك الحقيقي لان هو الضابط الحقيقي
المتربي
متربي عسكريا
حتى اسريا لان ابن ضابط ويواجه كل هاي
المشاكل بهاي القضيه اللي بها ارتباطات قد
تؤدي الى مشاكل كثيره فهو يكون بوجه
المدفع سامر حكمه مخرج العمل ابن الواقع
مهموم دائما بالواقع يبحث عن المشكلات
اللي اللي تركت اثر كبير بالواقع وهي
وظيفه الدراما ودورها هي ان تقتنص من
الواقع وتحولها الى حكايات ودورها ان تسلط
الضوء عليها وتحاول تعالجها او تكشفها
للمجتمع
بالمغامره خارج العراق داخل العراق